the formula that we just derived for the
monotonic case has a nice intuitive
explanation that we will develop now
suppose that G is a monotonic function
of X and that it's monotonically
increasing let us fix a particular X and
a corresponding Y so that the two of
them are related as follows y is equal
to G of little X or we could argue in
terms of the inverse function so that X
is equal to H of Y recall that H is the
inverse function that given a value of y
tells us which one is the corresponding
value of X now let us consider a small
interval in the vicinity of this little
X whenever X falls somewhere in this
range then Y is going to fall inside
another small interval the event that X
belongs here is the same as the event
that Y belongs there so these two events
have the same probability and we can
therefore write that the probability
that Y falls in this interval is the
same as the probability that X falls in
the corresponding little interval on the
x-axis this interval has a certain
length Delta one this interval has a
certain length Delta two now remember
our interpretation of probabilities of
small intervals in terms of PDFs so this
probability here is approximately equal
to the PDF of Y evaluated at the point Y
times the length of the corresponding
interval similarly on the other side the
probability that X falls on that
interval is the PDF of
times the length of that interval
so this gives us already a relation
between the PDF of Y and the PDF of X
but it involves those two numbers Delta
1 and Delta 2 how are these two numbers
related if X moves up by amount of Delta
one
how much is y going to move up it's
going to move up by an amount which is
Delta 1 times the slope of the function
G at that particular point so that gives
us one relation that Delta 2 is
approximately equal to Delta 1 times the
derivative of the function G at that
particular X however it's more useful to
work the other way
thinking in terms of the inverse
function the inverse function maps Y to
X and it Maps y plus Delta 2 to X plus
Delta 1 when y advances by Delta 2x is
going to advance by an amount which is
how much Y advanced times the slope or
the derivative of the function that
map's y's into X's and this function is
the inverse function so this is the
relation that we're going to use and so
we replace Delta 1 by this expression
that we have here in terms of Delta 2
and now we cancel the delta 2 from both
sides of this equality and we obtain the
final formula that the PDF of Y
evaluated at a certain point is equal to
the PDF of X evaluated at the
corresponding point or we could write
this as the PDF of X evaluated at the
value little X that's associated to that
Y that's given by the inverse function
times the derivative of the function age
the inverse function and this is just
the same formula as the one that we had
derived earlier using CD f's this
derivation is quite intuitive it
associates probabilities of small
intervals on the x-axis to probabilities
of corresponding small intervals on the
y-axis these two probabilities have to
be equal and this implies a certain
relation between the two PDFs